uh can i ask you a question brady
what is the most difficult way to uh
earn a million dollars
making youtube videos
well
you probably know much more about that
than i do one of the most difficult ones
is to solve one of the millennium
problems
in mathematics which were set by
the clay mathematical institute in the
year 2000. one of these problems is
called the riemann hypothesis
and it refers to a work of german
mathematician bernard riemann which he
did in uh in the year 1859 so this is
just one of the problems in fact there
are seven and only one of them has been
solved so far and interestingly enough
the person who solved the problem has
declined the 1 million dollars so
it just shows that mathematicians work
on these problems not because they want
to make some money i think it is now the
most
famous problem in mathematics it took
the place of herma's last theorem which
was uh solved by andrew wiles and and
richard taylor in the mid 1990s that
wasn't a millennium problem that was not
a million problem the most essential
thing here is what we call the the
riemann zeta function
and the riemann zero function is a
function so a function is a rule which
assigns to every value some other a
certain number a riemann zeta function
it assigns a certain number to any value
of s and that number is given by the
following series 1
divided by 1 to the power s plus 1
divided by 2 to the power s plus 1
divided by 3 to the power s 4 to the s
and so on so for example if we set s
equals 2 zeta of 2
is going to be 1 divided by 1 squared
plus 1 divided by two squared plus one
divided by three squared plus one
divided by four squared and so on so
what is this this is one this is one
over four this is one over nine one over
sixteen so this is an example of what
mathematicians call it a convergence
series
which means that if you sum up the first
n terms you will get an answer
which will get closer and closer to some
number and that number to which which it
approximates is called the limit
but the limit here is actually very
interesting and uh it has been a famous
problem in mathematics to find that
limit it's called the basel problem
named after the city of basel in
switzerland and this bicycle program was
solved by a great mathematician they are
not earlier and the answer is very
surprising what earlier showed is that
this sums up
2 pi
squared over 6. and so you may be
wondering what does this sum have to do
with the circle why would pi or pi
square
show up but rather came up with a
beautiful proof i'm not going to explain
it now but
it's something which you can easily find
online this series is just one example
of this riemann zeta function but you
can try to do the same for any uh other
value of s
so for example if you take s equals
three you will get the reciprocals of
all the cubes and you sum them up and so
on so this will again be a convergent
series and you can wonder what the
answer is that would be zeta of three
you can also try to substitute uh
negative numbers and this is very
interesting because if you substitute if
you just substitute s equals negative
one then what are we going to get so you
will get 1 divided by 1 to the 1 to the
negative 1 plus 1 to the 2 to the
negative 1 plus 1 to the
1 over 3 to the negative 1. if you take
the reciprocal of something which is the
inverse of something then you will get
that thing so so this would be one
this will be two
this will be three
this will be four does this does it look
familiar yes i have seen that before we
have arrived at the famous uh sum of all
natural numbers 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4
but you see now we obtain it in the
context of the zeta function so this
is what we call a divergent series there
is no
obvious way how we could possibly assign
a finite value to it this sum is
infinite
it does not converge to any finite value
but this context if we put this value
this infinite sum in the context of this
function there is actually a way to
assign a value to to this uh to s equals
negative one and this is what riemann
explained in his paper and so what
riemann said is that actually let we
should allow s to be not just a natural
number like for example two or three or
four when the series is convergent but
we should allow also all possible real
real numbers and not only real numbers
but also complex numbers the way you get
complex numbers is by realizing that
within real numbers you cannot find a
square root of negative one so what to
do one way is to ban the band square
root of negative one it's cut and say
this doesn't exist we cannot use it but
in mathematics we have understood long
time ago that actually there is a
there's a much better way to treat this
a square root of negative 1 we can
simply adjoin it to real to the real
numbers think of real numbers as points
on the line here 0
and here is 1 and here is 2 and then you
could mark your favorite fractions for
example one half is exactly the middle
way the middle way between zero and one
and say uh one and one third would be
sort of a third of the way between one
and two but then you also have things
like square root of two for example
somewhere here and then there is pi
which is just to the right of 3. so all
real numbers live here
square root of negative 1 cannot be
found anywhere on this line but we don't
give up we say you know what let's
actually draw a plane let's draw another
coordinate system and let's mark square
root of negative 1 on this new
coordinate axis you see if we do that
then every point on this plane
becomes a number so that would be 2
times square root of negative one and if
i take three times but more than that so
let me find the number which is uh on
the intersection of this line i can draw
a vertical line which goes from two and
i can go just to draw a horizontal line
there is this point of intersection so
this is this point also will represent a
number which will be 2 plus 3 times
square root of negative 1. so in other
words the general number is going to
have what we call a real part that's the
projection onto this axis and and the
imaginary part that's the projection on
the vertical one the notation is a
little bit clumsy instead of square root
of negative 1 they write i so then for
example instead of writing 2 plus 3
square root of negative 1
we'll just write 2 plus 3 i it's an
imaginary number we imagine it we cannot
find it on this real line so we have
imagined it and then and then we have a
joined it in our imagination real
numbers comprise all points on the real
line on this on this axis and complex
numbers comprise all the points on this
brown paper if you could extend the
brown paper all the way to infinity
right so let's go back to riemann what
riemann's insight was that he said look
let's think of this argument of the of
the zeta function this this number s
initially we thought that s could be 2 3
4 and so on but then we realized that
actually any number any real number to
the right of to the right of number one
not including number one because
actually in this case you could not
assign a value it's it's a divergent
series and it goes to infinity but
anything to the right and i'm drawing
i'm marking it with red all of that for
all of them
this function is actually well defined
so but then we said we can actually do
more we can think of s as being a
complex number so instead of thinking of
s as just being a point on this line we
can take s anywhere it will be
convergent
if it is to the right of this line
so you see this is the line which sort
of
um
to the right of this line
leave all the complex numbers whose real
part is greater than one so it turns out
and it's very easy to show that anywhere
in the shaded area except for this slide
except for this line to the right of
this line
for any value of s in this area
this function is converges to something
so if i put 6 plus 9 i into the riemann
zeta function i'll get a conversion
that's right you'll get a convergent
series it will convert to something
which is not going to be a real number
it's going to be a complex number
because you're going to add up
infinitely many complex numbers but
there will be a certain number to which
which will be closer and closer
approximated as you go along summing up
this series so so far basically
everything to the right of this line
gives us a bonafide value we'll come out
to play we'll come out to play will give
us a bona fide of value can the
imaginary part go negative but the
imaginary part yes dimensional part is
okay can be negative or positive but the
real part has to be greater than one but
now you are in the in the context of a
theory of
functions with complex argument and it
is what we call a holomorphic function
so it has some very special very nice
properties so the one of the properties
that this kind of what we call
holomorphic functions enjoy is what we
call analytic continuation so we can
conti we can extend the definition the
domain of definition of the function
there are methods which allow which
enable us to kind of push the boundary
and kind of and go and expand the domain
in which the function is defined and in
his seminal paper riemann
did precisely that he explained how to
extend
the this function to all possible values
except for one so there's only one value
where there is nothing you can do that
somehow it will be undefined and this is
we call this a poll or a singularity and
what is that value that value is
actually s equals one
so this is somehow this is a bad point
in some sense this is a point where we
cannot extend it's an and oh there's
zero i component there's no imaging
that's right so this this is a point
which is actually a real number so it's
funny because you would think that one
is in some sense easier
better than i but at i this function
will be perfectly well defined but at
one it will not be multified it will
have a singularity but luckily it's the
only singularity so what it means in
particular is that there is a way to
assign
a value to negative one so in other
words that there is a value zeta of
negative one whereby zeta we now mean
this extended function function under
analytically continued to the whole
complex plane and that's and that value
will be
you guessed it minus one over 12. it is
in the sense that people say you could
regularize the sum 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus
4 and assign to it the value of minus 1
over 12 because it shows up as the value
of the zeta function where naively you
are supposed to get 1 plus two plus
three plus four but now you are getting
this value by a much more sophisticated
procedure by starting with a complex of
as a function of a complex argument and
extending it beyond the initial domain
of definition so no matter what number i
pluck from here or here or here or here
or here and feed it into the function
i'll get a number of some sort you will
get a well-defined number uniquely
defined number and you can calculate it
on a computer because it is this number
can be represented by some integral for
example there is an explicit formula for
it okay so and you will calculate i will
calculate we'll get the same result
there is no ambiguity the only point
where it's not well defined is the point
s equals one this is like the achilles
here
it's a it's an achilles heel that's a
very good way to put his naked
heel of that function but and it's it's
very important it's responsible for a
lot of things that's what's happening to
it so it's a very important point so
riemann hypothesis is the following it's
about the zeros of of of this zeta
function in other words it's a question
about for what values
for which s
we have
zeta of s equals zero
that is a one million dollar question
for which values
of s do we have
does this function equal zero
and so
riemann
uh
here there is uh one one one point that
one has to make which is that there are
some sort of obvious zeros so it just it
just so happens that the value at
negative two for example is equal to
zero the negative
four is equal to zero
so in other words all the even negative
numbers for some reason it just so
happens and you can see it for example
from the functional equation easily
that uh the the value is just going to
be zero so there are some obvious zeros
so to speak which we already know the
question is what else where else are
these where are the other zeros and it's
actually
very easy to see
that all other zeros have to be
concentrated in this one in this one
strip so on one side of the strip is the
vertical line is the vertical axis and
on the other side of the strip is this
line when real part is one
and so let's sh let's so this is called
the critical strip
these are all the complex numbers for
which the real part is between zero and
one and so inside this critical strip
there is a middle line
for which the real value is one half and
we look at all the numbers for which
this is a real part for example half
plus
five i
will be a point somewhere here so it
will be on this line and what riemann
suggested the number of zeros is the
minimal possible they all concentrate
along this critical line according to
human hypothesis which still hasn't been
proved his hypothesis is
that all the zeros to his function
lie on that
line except except for these ones
exactly all the zeros lie on that line
on that vertical line which goes through
the point one half that is exactly the
statement of human hypothesis so the so
the way one way to disprove the
hypothesis would be to find a zero
somewhere in that blue shader exactly we
know that all of them are going to be in
the blue shaded area
the question is whether they are on this
one specific line
and uh believe me a lot of people have
been looking for a counter example which
by the way one wins a million dollars if
one proves riemann hypothesis or
disproves it so if somebody could find a
point in here
which is a zero but is not on this line
will also win a million dollars so a lot
of people have been searching but
haven't been able to find it have a lot
of zeros being found on the line yes
a huge number i don't remember but i
think trillions of numbers so all the
zeros that have been found are on this
line and there's there's constantly uh
search going on for more and more the
way i explained it it sounds like an
esoteric problem but actually in this
case there is more to this that meets
the eye
because riemann in that amazing paper
that he wrote in 1859 he also explained
that
this um behavior of
his zeta function which is now called
after him the riemann zero function and
more specifically the uh
the behavior and location of the zeros
of that function
has a direct uh bearing on the
distribution of prime numbers
and prime numbers are incredibly
important so prime numbers are you know
something that people have been studying
for millennia right so riemann was able
to connect the properties of this
function to the distribution of prime
numbers
and he
obtained a beautiful formula which tells
you how many prime numbers there are say
between one and one hundred between one
and one thousand between one and one
million for any uh n between one and n
using his zeta function which is
absolutely astonishing because if you
think about zero function
something has to do with complex numbers
and with analytic continuation and so on
and so forth so it's a particular branch
of mathematics which is called complex
analysis but prime numbers
live in a different branch of
mathematics in a number theory and it is
a big surprise that actually the two
things are very closely connected but
this relation that riemann found is
predicated on the riemann hypothesis
it's predicated on knowing that all the
zeros are located on this critical line
that's why this riemann hypothesis is so
important because it is only if we know
that riemann hypothesis holds that we
can obtain all these deep results about
uh distribution of prime numbers
in which we replace the series by their
sort of regularized values and i really
like to think of this regularized values
as sort of like
you know removing some of sort of like
there's a imagine like a piece of gold
which is surrounded by this infinite
amount of dirt and you kind of
throw away this dirt and you're left
with this little piece of gold so what
i'm trying to say is that